listening to that interview and the more
serious elements of it as well was a
labor she had a business secretary
Rebecca at Long Bailey she's in her
constituency in Sulphur for us this
morning thank you for being on the
program at miss Long Bailey well we just
heard from Boris Johnson who said that
if Jeremy Corbyn is Prime Minister after
the selection then we're gonna have two
referendums one and brexit and one on
Scottish independence is he right no I
mean what we've said is that were taking
a sensible approach after three years of
what have been quite shambolic
negotiations and the conduct of the
Conservative Party which has turned on
itself what we've said is that will
renegotiate a deal a sensible deal with
the European Union that puts our economy
working life and standards first and we
will put that deal to a public vote so
that people can decide whether that was
what they voted for and whether they're
happy to accept it so that is a
referendum then isn't it it's well it's
a referendum of sorts it's certainly not
a rerun of the original referendum I
think the position of that referendum is
perfectly clear where we are now is
determining whether the country is happy
with the final deal and they will have
their say in that final vote so in that
referendum that you are promising
will you campaign for leave will remain
well we'll make an assessment of the
deal at the time we'll try and get the
best deal that we possibly can we've set
out clearly what our negotiating
strategy would be a customs union strong
single market alignment a floor under
rights and protections and standards and
if we get all of that then we'll have a
conference with our Labour Party members
to determine how we will campaign in
that it could be the case that we get
70% of that and we have to make a
judgement on whether we think that the
final deal is good enough for us to take
forward but ultimately that decision
will be taken at the time so just to be
crystal clear then it seems pretty
obvious from what you're saying that
Labour's campaigning for a second
referendum and in that referendum it is
entirely feasible that labor could
campaign to leave the European Union
well we'll have to make that judgment at
the time based on the deal that we
managed set to Ghana from the European
Union but ultimately our priority has
always been to put our economy fir
to respect the result of the referendum
get the best deal that we possibly can
and ensure that we leave in a way that
doesn't damage our manufacturing
industry that doesn't strip away workers
rights and protections that doesn't take
away our environmental and consumer
standards and that's why we will examine
the final deal very very closely to make
sure that it underpins everything that
we've been setting out for the last
three years so that's the question again
because it's pretty clear you could
campaign to leave the EU in that
referendum that's right isn't it well
that will that will be a decision that
will be taken at the time by our party
we're a democratic party and that's why
we're having a special conference to
determine the final position but
ultimately underpinning our final
decision will be how good that deal is
we will try to get the most credible and
economically supportive deal that we
possibly can so that the British people
have the opportunity to choose upon a
deal that's credible that they will as
opposed to a deal that they've got at
the moment from Boris Johnson which
would strip away workers rights which
isn't economically credible we want to
give them the full choice and the
question at the beginning as well was
also talking about a Scottish
independence referendum could you rule
out a Labour government ever granting
another Scottish independence referendum
well it's certainly not something that
we're advocating under any circumstances
what we want to Scotland to be part we
want Scotland to be part of Great
Britain we think that we're fantastic
partners but ultimately what we have
said is that after the next Scottish
government elections if the Scottish
government determined that they want to
pursue another referendum and they go
through the legislative process within
their own government to push that
forward then there's a government we
wouldn't stand in their way we wouldn't
try and stop it but we certainly
wouldn't become painting to advocate
that Scotland leaves the United Kingdom
at all okay and interesting stuff and
pretty clear onto there I think and now
I'm keen to talk about your policy
announcement today because labour is
saying that if you win the next election
you want to insulate every home in the
United Kingdom just tell me exactly what
it is that you're proposing yes it's
well it's the largest upgrade to UK
housing since the post-war period
and it's not just insulating homes it's
also introducing new renewable
technologies like he solar so that you
could heat your hot water with solar
panels for example and other renewable
technologies and what we'd be doing was
offering that opportunity to every
single home in the UK we estimate that
it would cut at cases of asthma by five
hundred thousand by 2030 it would
eliminate fuel poverty by the mid-2020s
Engel household bill would go down and
the interesting part because ultimately
you will be wanting to talk about costs
there is no upfront costs to anybody who
wants to take part in this scheme those
who are on low-income salaries or or
incomes they will not have to pay a
penny they will receive a grant to be
able to carry out this work on their
homes those who are able to pay they
won't pay any upfront costs they will
have decreasing bills and a small
portion of that decreasing bill will be
used in the long term to pay for the
work that's been carried out so nobody
will be out-of-pocket as part of this
scheme you're right I do want to talk
about the money and it's interesting
that you say there's going to be no
upfront cost to the individuals which
may be right but there clearly are going
to be upfront costs when you have to pay
for this you have to pay for the people
who come into the houses to do the work
you have to pay for materials and those
upfront costs have to be met by somebody
and I have to say when I looked at the
figures for this it is quite staggering
I mean this policy is going to cost you
estimate 250 billion pounds you're gonna
provide 60 billion pounds of government
funds now that's 50% more than the
entire defense budget it's two thirds of
the size the Department for Education
annual budget I mean how on earth you're
gonna find that money well 60 billion
will be the direct capital government
investment that will come out of our
national transformation I'm talking
about down of the to the river well the
remainder of the 250 will be civilian
first I just want to talk about the 60
billion fast because the 60 billion
pounds is an awful lot of money and I'm
asking you where you're gonna get it
from so it will come out of our national
transformation fund which is the 250
billion pot of capital investment
expenditure that John McCauley sets out
at the last general election
so borrowing so yes it would be but
ultimately what we've factored into all
of this we've done financial modeling
that shows that that sixty billion will
be the government's outlay in the
initial stages but overall we're looking
at generating over four hundred thousand
jobs and supporting businesses
throughout the economy so by 2030 the
increased tax take v80 corporation tax
national insurance income tax more than
recoup that sixty billion pounds outlay
in fact it creates a surplus the
interest-free loans as I say that will
represent the remainder of the
expenditure and that will be repaid over
time through savings on bills themselves
and so that's the sixty billion pounds
one hundred and ninety billion pounds of
it is going to come from energy savings
just explain to me how that's going to
work because clearly energy savings will
only come over time it could be a few
years until you managed to get that
money back so bills will go down in
every home will be different some homes
will need double glazing some homes will
only need loft insulation some homes
will need the full suite of things that
are on offer from floor insulation to
loft insulation to cavity wall
insulation to all of the renewable
technologies that were installing to
bring you know heating bills down and
bills will go down very very quickly and
there will be a portion of that bill
that are saving if you like that will be
allocated to repaying the interest-free
loan the rest of the saving will be
enjoyed by the bill pay so they won't be
paying anything extra at all on top of
what they're paying now I'll be
perfectly clear about that okay now
while we're talking about money and la
4mp this week at Lloyd Ross and Moyles
said and I don't think that anyone in
this country should be a billionaire do
you agree with it
well I think in terms of where our
economies are at the moment we're seeing
inequality increasing on an
unprecedented scale a group called the
economic justice commission a few years
ago brought out a report into prosperity
and economic justice within the UK that
was made up of experts right across the
UK academics and business leaders
who stated very very clearly that our
economy was fractured and unless we
change the way that we operate it the
economy wasn't sustainable going forward
and we were not going to address the
inequality question so what we need to
see happening and this is certainly a
central pillar of Labor's economic
offering is a rebalancing of our economy
and that goes all the way through from
investing in areas that haven't seen
investment for many decades rebalancing
the way our economy works in terms of
corporate governance installing workers
on boards for example so the executive
remuneration and the pay of workers is
increased so that that's fairer it's
also about making sure that our benefit
system and Social Security is fit for
purpose and it's also about making those
critical investments in industrial
strategy that improve productivity and
our green industrial revolution is one
central pillar of that a huge economic
lever that we're going to use to
kick-start the economy and deal with the
climate crisis the same time that's very
different isn't it talking about the
need to rebalance the economy and saying
nobody in the whole of the country
should be a billionaire particularly
when you take into account that the top
1% of earners actually paid 27 percent
the country's income tax I mean too many
people listening they'll think this just
sounds like the politics of envy it's
not the politics of envy I think that
Lloyd Russell Moyer was highlighting the
staggering inequality that we see in
Great Britain that makes many people
angry there's nothing wrong with working
hard and certainly we advocate that you
work hard do well but ultimately we've
got a moral responsibility all of us to
pay tax and to improve the communities
in which we live but we also can't be
within an economy that sees people
sleeping on the streets and homeless
those who are going to food banks just
to receive food many of whom are
actually in paid work at the moment and
think we must recognize that there are
fundamental problems in our economy that
have to be addressed of course we want
people to do well and we want to
celebrate that but we also need to
recognize that something fundamentally
has to change so that we're not seeing
this inequality which quite frankly is
akin to Victorian times at the moment
and just very quickly John McDonnell
says he wants the next leader of the
a party to be a woman you been lined up
well at the moment we are getting Jeremy
Corbyn elected as prime minister so that
on December 12 we can absolutely
transform our economy and deal with the
inequality that we've just been talking
about but not only that offer a
transformational program that offers
hope for the future looks at a green
industrial revolution that will upgrade
every single home and usher in a new era
of public luxury that we haven't seen
for many many decades and that's quite
exciting I'm excited about it and I'll
be doing everything I can in this
election campaign to make sure that that
happens okay thank you very much for
going to show apologies if there were
any audio issues there thanks very much